russian forces are surrounding cities
crippling humanitarian supply chains and
escape routes in what appears to be a
new and disturbing tactic of slowly
starving civilians tonight our jeff
semple lies near odessa ukraine where
food and water are running out
in normal times the odessa food market
serves an eclectic mix of seafood pasta
and pints but these are not normal times
today volunteers are collecting and
dishing out medicine blankets and other
life-saving supplies to civilians and
soldiers fighting on the front line
which is only about 100 kilometers from
here
we have a little gap of time to prepare
our city before the war inga kordinovska
ran a law firm now she runs a
humanitarian volunteer center with most
businesses closed they're providing food
for thousands but three weeks into the
war supplies are already running out we
don't have russian occupation in the
city but it's really difficult to find
some very necessary things especially
medicines russia's push into parts of
ukraine appears to have stalled but its
military is choking ukraine's supply
chains according to the country's
president
appearing in another defiant video
vladimir zelinski said russia is trying
to starve civilians into submission the
stark choice now facing ordinary
ukrainians stay and risk dying from
fighting or starvation or leave but for
some that cost is also unbearable this
has fast become a heart-wrenching
routine since the invasion regular rail
service is suspended but every day these
free trains arrive to take women and
children who want to leave out of the
country anna and her eight-year-old
daughter came to catch a train to poland
even though it means leaving her husband
and her mother behind
we couldn't wait any longer we have to
go where there's still an opportunity
but we're leaving with a heavy heart she
said ukrainian men are required to stay
behind and fight this crowd is full of
families who may be seeing each other
for the last time
as the train arrives there's a scramble
to get on board to secure a spot leaving
no time for a proper goodbye
many like anna's husband linger outside
the window as long as they can savoring
every last moment before the train
carrying their wives and children pulls
away
but many residents of odessa remain
trying to carry on even as russian
forces inch closer
we are doing our best trying to live a
normal life he says on a sunny saturday
the city's main market was packed
odessa's largest jazz club is closed
because of the war so the musicians
performed from the balcony people need
some bright light during all this stuff
russia has more soldiers a much bigger
military but ukraine's spirit feels
insurmountable
jeff semple global news odessa